hello my name is Vinod spla my
consulting technologies for Wolfram and
today I'm going to explain how I've
developed several websites that I call
war from micro sites using the war from
cloud today angra talk about my dress
and examples using the wall from cloud
these are war from micro sites most of
them try to future one of the the core
functions that we have for example
family tour is featuring the forum page
with with the travel directions and find
shortest tour there are three functions
being featured in these websites and
then i'm going to talk as well about the
project that is called a hackathon
project generator it tries to combine
ideas and actions and it's providing you
random ideas that you can do during a
hackathon then i will show how i built a
really simple system to maintain the
teach wolframalpha your sense of humor
using to form pages and the data drop so
you can add new questions and remove all
ones that you want to be displayed in
that page so if you know how to survive
a zombie attack i encourage you to go
there and answer that it's going to be
useful this kind of humor in the Wolfram
Alpha finally I'm going to provide an
overview of a project that I'm currently
doing and it that's the code card sue
gallery you provide the name a date and
then a location it's providing simple
code cards with two lines of foreign
language code and it's being displayed
using the Wolfram language and each
individual card has an API on it first
of all I will start with a simple form
function that was created for an
exclusive vice cleaning that Wolfram was
how holding about the the the man who
knew infinity that so
I sent that form and it's basically a
form that sends some information of the
attendees today tab in and in this case
I used Adelaide to display a doobie
small counter so you can see here that
they are like 293 sports available so I
was asking for the first name last name
and then the number of guests at each
attendee was was bringing with him and
depending on the on them if the if the
if there was a sports available then I
was showing a response to thank you
message but if it was full then the user
was receiving why waiting list response
saying that if this is a space that
there is going to be sent the good way
that using data bin was what you can to
be format clear information and
structure it so you get the final list
of people so what was a very simple for
invention that's not actually a
microsite so he let me go no explain
that the fields one that's family tour
so in this case family tour you can
introduce several cities that you want
to visit so let's say you know goes also
to LA and then you wait a while and then
you get travel directions to visit all
these cities so first of all is using
find shortest tour and then tries to
look at travel directions and if there
are travel directions for this
particular cities it displays that or if
they are not if the term elections fails
it means that you have to take a plane
then it displays that the simple jo-jo
lease plot of that locations
actually just adding some like
backgrounds and styles it just added a
bit of more lines of code but the core
functionality of how it works is just a
simple form page where you have like the
repeating elements that you can
introduce more cities if the user wants
to hear you specify that the initial
that you want three city is a list and
then the total can be up to ten cities
in at this time because sometimes you
want to display the point but yeah just
a stupid thing but yeah so that's the
simple example so what what was deemed
that the real form page is in this case
I'm using large cities of Canada to show
the example is I'm taking the the
coordinates the geo positions of them
then looking at the fine shortest tour
that's giving me the the right ordering
of the cities to visit and then you get
the geo least plot of that if you ask
for the double directions is going to
find all the directions there there are
sometimes you have to take a ferry but
in this case it worked well and if it
fails then I'm having a conditional to
return just the simple path in this case
the she always plot so that's the main
construction of this microsite let's
move to the project generator the big
challenge of this project was to collect
a good enough list of do's and lists of
things so you can get neisseria in
matching of them so you have the older
pairs combining all these lists and for
each one of the ideas and induce I got
an association with them with related
documentation pages and functions and
then also blog posts that are related
and can be used
for that particular project so when you
combine them you end up with with a
spinner and then you get these different
sections with the relevant pensions for
the particular project and the different
related the resources that you can take
a look the the spinner effect was done
with a loafer language is just a simple
gif animation and it's just using the
blur filter processing images and looks
like an effect it's a slot machine
combining ideas and actions thus then
there are some some functions just too
too much and take everything and I'm not
these snippets of code as HTML using the
bootstrap classes just to look nice but
that's a separate question so the this
is actually an API so this API had the
whole have 700 ideas there so which one
is number and if the user is introducing
one for example 0 or like 900 then I'm
just going to redirect them to the full
list so I'm looking for the limitation
there any ideas so it's just an API that
refreshes every time someone is visiting
it and yeah let's move to the dealer 1
and that case is the teacher Wolfram
Alpha your sense of humor it was an idea
to add more well where's the Wolfram
Alpha Team is seeing a lot of questions
being sent by users that are not
possible to do it right now with at once
or them but with this project prolly
they
be possible to answer funny questions
that people are sending 12 from alpha
and I want to say that it's really basic
thing that I did to construct it the
back end is just working with three data
beans one for the questions the other
one for answers and another one for
which of these questions have to be
hidden so I created a form page to add
new questions for the system and me
administrator in this case for example
we can add the questions who I do so
zombie attack you can add more if you
want and then you submit their and this
forum page is going to be redirecting
you to the other forum page that's it's
a way to hide or unhide the questions so
I'm getting to this one I have currently
four questions I'm displaying all of
them so I submit them are not generating
the updating the website I deciding the
question I just studied right there so
the user can and enter the answer and
all the information that he wants so
it's a really simple way to maintain it
and it just works with these three
simple things they also had an epi to
send an email saying thank you for
submitting your question it's also
inside the the final page that is only
the HTML template it was using but i'm
not going to go through it yeah that's
the questions so for example i can say
that i don't want this to go here and
then you get only two questions oops i
have to check that I mean I just build
up this site just for my account yeah
I was not called connected in these
things well yeah
so the final microsite that was isn't
one I'm that I'm still working on it and
body is also helping me is here and is
basically these cold cards and each one
of these cards is a an API that
generating a vector graphics and it
consists basically with the input that's
the Wolfram language code that's going
to be displayed and an output cell and
she's just an example so it looks like
play now and these individual api's are
what's going to be shown in the final
gallery if you if you add a different
name say not it's going to read it as a
given name and then it's going to take
the real wort and look at the
additionally look up and I saying this
these words are quite similar and then
it's generating the clustering three in
this la layout so let me show you the
final page that it sits I know it's
working like that several workouts like
for example this wise looking at all I
told the cities of the US and then
finding the ones that are named like
yours in this case the one that's
provided so you can go out here and
introduce different information and
you're going to get different code cards
so I am giving you a list of resources
you hope you are going to find these
micro sites useful for your own projects
and you're going to be deploying
websites to the warfront cloud here it
is a full list of functionalities that's
really the resting to use and there are
new ones that for example Carlo and his
team is a building so we are seeing a
lot of progress and there are more
different functions that you can use to
deploy all sorts of websites I'm also
providing the how it works for these
micro sites and there are a few that I
have not mentioned because I was not
really involved with them geremy Davis
is the one who styleite them in a really
nice way and if you have questions about
the final things that you can ask the
him but the way it it's explained it's
quite good I mean you can go there and
see how it was deployed or that the core
idea was was done yeah then I also
encourage you to go to the warfarin
community there are also other users
deploying micro sites and giving
examples so i would like to finish here
and if you have questions i'm here to
answer some questions thank you
[Applause]